newly released police dispatch audio
from the school massacre in Uvalde Texas
reveals widespread miscommunication
during the police response at Roe at Rob
rather elementary school so we already
know of the extensive failures by
officers during this attack in May
killed 19 students and two teachers
these recordings obtained by Texas
Tribune and pro-publica show the
desperation inside the school during 77
very long minutes of Terror Omar
villafranca is in Uvalde Omar good
morning just when you think the story
can't get worse you hear more things
that are so upsetting
good morning the 9-1-1 calls are
disturbing you can hear the panic and
the fear in the adults we also hear the
scared voices of kids who are calling
9-1-1 while hiding from the shooter we
want to warn you what you're about to
hear may be disturbing
as the shooter entered Robb Elementary
School and after Witnesses had already
called 9-1-1 twice police dispatchers
received this third frantic Culp at 11
33 a.m
at the kids three minutes later police
received this call from teacher Monica
Martinez who survived the shooting she
was hiding in a closet
there's somebody banging at my school
are you in by 11 50 a.m authorities say
the gunman had fired more than 100
rounds and was still barricaded in the
classroom but at that time a police
dispatcher incorrectly stated that the
school's police chief Pete Arredondo was
in the room with the shooter 20 minutes
later then ten-year-old student Chloe
Torres called 9-1-1 from her classroom
room 112 and more than 25 minutes after
that at 12 36 PM Chloe who survived
called again to beg for help
I go into my room I already told them to
go to the room we're trying to get
someone to you law enforcement didn't
breach the classrooms until 12 50. more
than an hour after the gunman entered
the school Javier casares lost his
ten-year-old daughter Jackie in the
shooting he hasn't listened to all of
the 911 audio that told us this about
what he did here
wouldn't imagine was unbearable it could
even just knowing what that video I mean
that that call was about
you know it's hard here it just broke us
you know and with less than a week until
midterm elections the massacre at Robb
Elementary is front of mind for victims
families members of the Uvalde Community
assembled at the Texas state capitol
Tuesday night as part of a Dia de los
Muertos demonstration the Mexican
tradition celebrates the memories of the
dead but this Gathering took on a more
somber and political tone when you're
voting make the right choice
be our children's voices in love with us
please
because this country needs to change the
state needs a change
people here have been very vocal about
getting out the vote earlier this week
one of the mothers of the victim said of
elected officials if our children are
not safe neither are your jobs meanwhile
the state senator from Uvalde is pushing
legislation to create a 300 million
dollar Uvalde victims fund Vlad
incredibly heartbreaking Omar thank you
very much